our subject
my god and i
my god and i extending this invitation
to me to fellowship with you on this
very historic weekend in the history of
the boston temple esther church i
consider myself privileged and i thank
god for it and i thank you
the word vesper suggests shortness so i
will not delay you long i'll be a little
longer tomorrow during the divine
service but i want to place before you
some bible truths tonight that i hope
you will find reassuring and that will
strengthen your relationship with your
god
and that will make you more equipped to
reach out to others and give them the
reassurance
that there is a personal god who loves
them
intimately
and deeply
welcome again and let me extend a
welcome to anyone watching who is not a
seventh-day adventist i particularly
welcome you we're always honored
as servant of the adventists to have
guests among us so if you're listening
and watching and you are not a
seventh-day adventist
thank you very much for joining us
and may the lord bless you for
apportioning some of your time to
fellowship with us i also extend a
particular welcome to little boys and
little girls who may be listening with
their parents children learn a lot more
than we suspect and so little brothers
little sisters thank you very much for
listening and may god bless you and
always remind you that jesus was at one
time a little child and he was a good
little child as i believe you also are
but i'm not sure if we're seen in other
countries but just in case we are
wherever you are thank you very much and
may god bless you super abundantly
before i get into the message do three
little favors for me where you are one
preserve reverence where you are with
all i'm thinking slightly
you're getting your time
i can hear some conversations going on
right now be sure to mute the microphone
on your phone the fact that we're on
zoom does not reduce the holiness of god
god is always holy
with it and just do what you do
i continue to hear discussions please
mute your microphone for the sake of
reference
you're not muted sister zena
i'd like you to pray for me while i'm
speaking all i want you to say is lord
put your words in that man's mouth
that request is based in jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 which says
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth and this is an
earnest request from me to you
ask god to put his words
in my mouth
and favor number three it may sound odd
i want you to think as you listen
concentrate
apply your mind apply that considerable
intellect that god has blessed you with
isaiah 1 18 tells us come now let us
reason together set the lord god invites
us to reason he comes down and he
reasons with us he came down to the
garden of eden to talk to adam and eve
he reasoned with cain god is a reasoning
and a reasonable god the devil is
unreasonable but god is reasonable let's
bow our heads and pray
father in heaven we thank you for the
gift of life
we thank you thank god for your constant
watch care
for the way you provide so abundantly
our needs
above all we thank you for the gift of
your dear son jesus christ for his
sacrifice his sinless life his voluntary
death and his tremendous and powerful
resurrection conquering death hell sin
the grave of satan
as we bow in your presence that god in
this act of worship if we've offended
you
forgive us their god the bible says in
micah 7 18 he delighteth in mercy and
there is no greater act of mercy than
forgiveness of sins
now father
place your words in my mouth i pray
pour out a special blessing and all
those who are with us
who are not sever they haven't just
a sweet blessing on all the children
their god
and if anyone listening to me has
contracted covet 19 i ask in the name of
christ who healed everyone who came to
him
heal those persons their god father i am
not praying simply for improvement i am
asking you heal them completely if they
have contracted cover 19 and anyone else
with aches and pains their god place
your hand of mercy upon them i pray and
i offer this prayer in jesus name
amen
go with me to psalm 23.
it's a well-known psalm perhaps the most
popular
passage of scripture in all the bible
next to john 3 16.
stan
popularly known as the shepherd psalm
and we shall read it more than once
excuse me
i am reading from the king james version
of the bible
so my language may sound slightly
different from whatever version you may
have before you
psalm 23
reading from verse 1
the lord is my shepherd
i shall not want
he maketh me to lie down in green
pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters
he restoreth my soul
he leadeth me in the paths of
righteousness for his name's sake
yea though i walk through the valley of
the shadow of death
i will fear no evil
for thou art with me thy rod and thy
staff they comfort me
thou preparest a table before me in the
presence of mine enemies
thou announce my head with oil my cup
runneth over surely
goodness and mercy shall follow me all
the days of my life
and i will dwell in the house of the
lord
forever
our subject
my god and i
let us read that psalm again
this time we will identify all
the personal pronouns
that relate to the psalmist that's david
we'll see how many times pronouns are
used referring to david remember our
subject is my lord and i
the lord is
my shepherd that's one
i shall not want let's do
he maketh me three to lie down in green
pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters
he restoreth my soul
he leadeth me in the pads of
righteousness for his name sake ye
though i walk through the valley of the
shadow of death i will fear no evil for
thou art with me thy rod and thy staff
they comfort me thou prepare us a table
before me in the presence of mine
enemies thou anointest my head with oil
my cup runneth over surely goodness and
mercy shall follow me all the days of my
life and i will dwell in the house of
the lord forever 17 references
in that little psalm
me i my this is david taking a personal
approach to his savior and his lord
jesus christ the lord is my shepherd now
it is left to you to say the lord is my
shepherd each of us must say that
individually
let's read the psalm again this time we
will look for the pronouns or nouns that
refer to god
we've looked at the pronouns that refer
to the psalmist david we're looking for
the pronouns that refer to god we saw 17
pronouns referring to david the psalmist
excuse me let's look for pronouns
referring to god
the lord is my shepherd
i shall not walk
he
maketh me to lie down
in green pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters
he
restoreth my soul he leadeth me in the
paths of righteousness for his name sake
yea though i walk through the valley of
the shadow of death i will fear no evil
for thou art with me thyroid thy stop
they comfort me thou preparest a table
before me thou prepare us a table before
me in the presence of my enemies thou
along this my cup with all my head with
oil my cup runneth over surely goodness
and mercy shall follow me all the days
of my life and i will dwell in the house
of the lord forever 11 references to god
and if you add the lord
in verse 1 and the last verse of that
psalm it is 13th time 13 times in that
little psalm we have references to god
17 times we have references to david
this is a personal psalm david is saying
the lord is my shepherd
i have a question for you
is god is christ your shepherd john
chapter 10 tells us he is the good
shepherd he calls himself the good
shepherd is christ your shepherd he must
be your individual shepherd yes we know
he died for the whole world we
understand that but john 3 16 will not
be useful to you unless you read it
first
as for god so loved me
that he gave his only begotten son that
if i believe in him i should not perish
but i will have eternal life
the lord is my shepherd
we shall go back to verse 1
and we look at verse 3 closely before i
do that let me pray again
father in heaven as i talk about christ
the shepherd whom you sent
give me simple language to god that the
beloved listening may get the message
clearly in jesus name i pray amen listen
carefully
read microscopically
the lord is my shepherd i shall not one
he maketh me to lie down in green
pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters
verse 3 he restoreth my soul now listen
to the ending of verse 3 he leadeth me
in the paths of righteousness for his
name's sake
not for yours
and i do not say that disrespectfully
but i want to say directly he that's
christ
leadeth me in the paths of righteousness
for his
name's sake
which means
that christ as your shepherd and mine
and i hope you'll say my shepherd as i
say my christ as my shepherd the
ultimate purpose is that god may be
glorified through this union of the
shepherd and the sheep he leadeth me in
the paths of righteousness for his
name's sake
let me make a statement that will humble
you and me
god always acts first
for his glory
when he made adam and eve he made them
isaiah 43 verse 7 i have created him for
my glory psalm 19 verse 1 the heavens
declared the glory of god the heavens
were created first to advertise the
glory of god isaiah 6 3 the whole earth
is full of his glory creation was
designed to reflect the glory of god and
the crowning work of creation mankind
should more clearly than sun moon stars
and brass reflect the glory of god i say
again my listening friend he leadeth me
in the paths of righteousness for his
name's sake
in psalm 25
verse 11 this time it says for thy name
say o lord pardon my iniquity for it is
great fall thy name say
pardon my iniquity
and psalm 130 reading verses three and
four i'm subject my lord and i
psalm 130 verses 3 and 4 if thou lord
should mark iniquities oh lord who shall
stand but there is forgiveness with thee
why that thou mayest be feared what does
that mean when we understand god is
prepared and willing and wanting and
waiting and ready to forgive any sin of
any side and any dimension it brings out
of us a sort of awe we look at god in
awe he forgives our sins that he might
be feared that he might be glorified so
that we can say like isaiah in isaiah 40
verse 20 verse 25
to whom then really likened me or shall
i be equal save the holy one or like
micah in micah 788 who is a god like
unto thee that pardon of inequity who in
the entire universe is so willing to
forgive
it is for the glory of god
and so we go back to verse 3 of psalm 23
he restoreth my soul
he leadeth me in the paths of
righteousness for his named sake now
why does god have to lead us in the
paths of righteousness
the answer is simple because no sinner
no one born with the carnal nature can
lead himself or herself in the paths of
righteousness why is that listen to
romans 8 verse 7
because the carnal mind is enmity
against god
for it is not subject to the law of god
neither indeed can be in other words it
is impossible for an unconverted person
to obey god's law to in a way that
pleases god the carnal mind finds
obedience impossible
then
someone must leave that person in the
paths of righteousness in romans chapter
3 from verse 10 as it is written there's
none righteous no not one there's none
that understand it there's none that
seeketh after god they're all gone out
of the world together gone out of the
way they're together become unprofitable
left to ourselves we cannot obey god
in a way that pleases god
we can comply with rules and regulations
on an outward basis at the behavioral
level we cannot produce a spiritual
nature
and so the psalmist says he
leadeth me
in the paths of righteousness what are
the paths of righteousness simply the
ten commandments why do i say that
ecclesiastes chapter 12 13 let us hear
the conclusion of the whole matter
fear god
and keep his commandments for this is
the whole
duty of man
all god requires is a life of obedience
willing obedience from the heart to his
commandments and so he has to lead us
into the paths of righteousness ezekiel
36 26 27 a new heart also will i give
you and a new spirit will i put within
you and i will take away the stony heart
out of your flesh i will give you a
heart of flesh and i will put my spirit
within you and cause you to walk in my
statute you shall keep my judgments i
says god will put my spirit within you i
will cause you to walk in my strategy i
will be the motivating force the the
energizing force that allows you to obey
a spiritual standard a divine standard
because god's law reflects a divine
standard how can a carnal person keep a
divine standard that person must be
changed
and even in that condition the person
needs divine power to guide him or her
and so this problem says he leads me in
the paths of righteousness for his name
say mother also teaches us as i said
earlier
our obedience to god
the ultimate purpose of our obedience to
god
is the glory of god we need to
understand that long long time ago i
don't need to get into several different
sermons
god was falsely accused by satan
his character was called into question
and the great controversy is god's
extended thousand-year attempt to clear
his name and to settle this controversy
and when we obey god we assist god in
clearing his name in bringing that
controversy to a conclusion where god is
justified and satan is rightly condemned
and destroyed your obedience my friend
brings glory to god the ultimate purpose
of your obedience is mine is the glory
of god in signs of the time
september 24 1894 paragraph four
signs at the time september 24 1894
paragraph four ella white writes
it is the prerogative of god alone to
prescribe the duty of men and angels the
will of god is a perfect will and must
be obeyed as it is set forth in his holy
law because every requirement is just
and is set forth by infinite wisdom the
law of god should be obeyed even though
there were no authority to enforce it
and no rewards for its obedience the
highest interests of men and angels
are conserved in obeying the law of god
god's will expressed in his law is the
supreme will and no invention no device
of man can take its place
obedience to the commandments of the men
instead of to the commandments of god
will be as abomination in the sight of
god now listen carefully for what god
requires is essential to the highest
good of his subject and is therefore
essential for the glory of god and what
is it god requires a life of obedience
to his law and elohim tells us when that
is the case
this
this is how god expresses his
his best for us our best interests are
served in obeying god and when we obey
god god is glorified that which god
requires
is essential to the highest good of his
subject
there is no higher state of living than
a life of willing obedience to god
and on this earth there is no greater
glory to god than the life of an
obedient person
he leaves me in the paths of
righteousness
for his
name let's say that sound again
the lord is my shepherd is he your
shepherd
is your personal god listen to this
quotation mind carton personality volume
two page 423 paragraph two
mind character and personality volume
two page four twenty three paragraph two
here's what ever white writes the gospel
deals with individuals
every human being has a soul to save or
to lose
each has a personality this separate and
distinct from all others each must be
converted from self convicted himself he
must repent be or believe obey the truth
for himself he must exercise his will
for himself the gospel deals first
with individuals and so the psalmist
says the lord is my shepherd
i shall not want because when you have
christ
you have everything
let me say that again
when you have christ
you have everything why is that christ
is the creator
and the bible says in colossians 1 verse
16 followed by him were all things
created that are in heaven and that are
in earth visible and invisible whether
they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers all things were
created by him and for him
the entire universe belongs to christ
and so when christ is your shepherd you
have everything you need in jesus christ
and he will dispense those blessings as
he determines you have need not as your
sense of whatever coveting dictates as
god sees we have need he dispenses his
grace and his blessings and his goodness
the lord
is my shepherd
that's christ
i shall not want
he maketh me to lie down
in great pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters
he restoreth my soul
he leadeth me in the paths of
righteousness for his named same i won't
go through the whole psalm i'll pause at
that point
as i conclude my lord and i
let christ lead you in the path of
righteousness
for his name
say let's see that expressed differently
here is the verse you know very well
first corinthians 10 31
let me pray again father as i continue
and i'm on the down slope of the message
please lord tell me what to say and how
to say it in jesus name i pray amen
first corinthians 10 31
whether therefore ye eat
or drink
or whatsoever you do one of my favorite
verses by the way it is not symbolic it
is literal
the verse ends this way do all to the
glory of god
he leadeth me in the paths of
righteousness for his namesake his
namesake is the same as do all to the
glory of god
in psalm 106 3 listen very carefully to
this verse
blessed are they that keep judgment and
he that doeth righteousness at
all
times not simply on sabbath at
all times so that a life led in the path
of righteousness by christ as the
shepherd is a life of continual
obedience to god and a life regards
glory is uninterruptedly reflected
let me add this
listen again the lord is my shepherd
i shall not want
he maketh me to lie down in green
pastures he leadeth me
for someone to be led
the person must be willing to be led
otherwise the person is dragged and
pulled god doesn't drag people he leads
people shepherds go ahead and the sheep
follow now he leadeth me because i
voluntarily i choose to be led by him
now we're not literal sheep we have
intelligence you see we have a
conscience we can make choices for
against god we must choose to allow
christ to lead us
and so the lord is my shepherd i shall
not run
he maketh me to lie down in greek
pastures he leadeth me
god wants to lead and direct your life
my listening friend but you must allow
him you must invite him to guide and
direct
supervise and superintend your life
apart from that
your life may seem to be successful
within a secular context within the
context of eternal salvation only a life
led by christ may be described as
successful because in god's eyes success
is not only in this life but a life to
come
first timothy chapter 4 verse 8
but bodily exercise prophet of nothing
but godliness is profitable unto all
things
having promised of the life that now is
and of the life to come godliness which
is a life of obedience to god is
profitable unto all things
having promise of the life that now is
and of the life to come so a successful
life in god's eyes is a life in which
that success extends into the life to
come there is no
interruption a triumphant life is a life
that extends from this life to the next
a victorious life goes from this to the
next
a secularly successful life that success
ends when jesus christ and that person
is lost
and so he leadeth me
in the paths of righteousness
for his
name to say
i said i'll close i said it earlier let
me say it now with definiteness i'm
closing
everything you and i do
we must first ask the question
is this for the glory of god
it must be us and it must be absent
i'll never forget i was preaching in a
certain country
in 215 and i was speaking to young
people
i was
talking about the principle of
making the glory of god your motivation
for everything and i
i told them no matter what you do if you
choose a dress ask yourself is this for
the glory of god why did i choose this
dress why did i choose that shoe why did
i choose that hairstyle why why why was
god's glory my motivating factor and i
made the presentation there we left the
next morning i was doing one-to-one
counseling and a young lady came to me
and during the sunday morning
presentation she had a hairstyle big
hairstyle a lot of
whatever you call these things that you
buy and you add them onto your head
she had that large and big but when she
came to see me it was gone
and i did not recognize her she said you
don't recognize me i said no she said i
am so and so i sat in this row i said oh
i said what happened she said i was so
convicted i realized i did not make this
style for the glory of god
and i went home i took it off completely
my listening friend
always choose for the glory of god
whether it's a spouse or a job or a
career moving from boston to san
francisco whatever it is ask the
question and try to develop precise
answers how will god be glorified why he
leadeth me in the paths of righteousness
for his name's sake and i must pound
that into your consciousness if you
don't mind for his named sake
that's how jesus lived john 8 29 and he
that have sent me is with me the father
hath not left me alone for i do always
those things that please him christ did
it for his name say
i leave you now
psalm 23 the first three verses
the lord is my shepherd i shall not want
he maketh me to lie down in green
pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters he
restoreth my soul
he leadeth me in the paths of
righteousness
for his
name's saying
it's a personal god
the sheep must agree to be led and the
sheep refers to us
make christ your shepherd personally
first before you try to talk to others
about christ as a savior be willing to
let him lead you and remember he leads
in the paths of righteousness and
righteousness is expressed in two ways
in two places the life of christ and the
law of god be virtually the same because
the life of christ is a living
expression of the law of god
my listening friend let's borrow heads
and pray father in heaven we thank you
so much for your word
we thank you for its simplicity when it
is read honestly and microscopically
we thank you to god you desire to have a
one-to-one relationship with humanity
regardless of age and stage
father if we've not seen as a personal
god forgive us father let us see you
tonight as my shepherd father this is
not selfishness this is accepting your
version of the gospel the foundation
stone of the gospel is the sacrifice of
christ for individuals
please god
let us with every passing day live our
lives
allow you to lead us in the paths of
righteousness for your name sake or for
your glory
bless everyone who listened a double
blessing on the little children their
god a special blessing and all our
guests who are not adventists if other
nations have connected bless those
nations bless the leaders and again
father if someone listening has scored
19 in the name of jesus christ your son
and our savior someone equal with
yourself in the name of the one who said
let there be light in the name of the
one who said i am the resurrection and
the life in the name of the one who said
i and my father are one in his name god
deliver those persons from covet 19 i
pray draw us to your muslim father and
let your bosom be our happiest place i
pray for my heart in jesus name amen
god bless you
i believe we have a close-knit song it
is 286.
it was something else but i suggested a
change and a change was made singing
them over again to me wonderful words of
life
sing them over again to me wonderful
words applied brother andrews playing
the piano
wherever you are sing
i'm not a good thing i'll try
sing
them over again to me
wonderful words
[Music]
words of life
words of life and beauty
teach me faith
[Music]
beautiful words
wonderful words
[Music]
[Applause]
wonderful words wonderful words of life
you may unmute your mics and sing i like
to hear
your words
wonderful words of love
beautiful words
wonderful
words of love
i believe that andrew has some closing
words